كيف تبدو لك هذه المواقف الاسرائيليه
المتضاربه حول صفقه تبادل الاسرى والى
ماذا تؤشر
كذلك يعني اول هذه المواقف التي ينبغي ان
نتوقف عندها هي مواقف بنيامين نتنياهو في
الحقيقه لان بنيامين نتنياهو يقدم اشارات
متناقضه اذا صفقه تبادل الاسرى التي يجري
الحديث عنها الان يفترض ان رئيس المساد لم
يذهب الى باريس ولم يشارك في هذه
المباحثات الا بتعليمات وتوجيهات من
بنيامين نتنياهو ويفترض ان الرئيس المساد
كان طرفا اساسيا مشاركا في صياغه المبادره
المطروحه على فصائل المقاومه الفلسطينيه
عموما وعلى قياده حركه حماس على وجه
التحديد ومن ثم حينما يتحدث بنيمين
نتنياهو بكلام مخالف لذلك فهذا يعني ان
بنمي نتنياهو في الحقيقه يراوغ ويريد ان
يكسب الوقت ويريد ان يلعب على كل الاطراف
لكن لا ينبغي ان نغفل بطبيعه الحال انه قد
يكون من نوايا الاحتلال الاسرائيلي محاوله
تجريد المقاومه الفلسطينيه من هذه الورقه
المهمه الموجوده ب بايديها وان بنيامين
نتنياهو يريد ان يقول في التالي للمجتمع
الاسرائيلي انه قادر على استعاده الاسرى
مع استمرار هذه الحرب وهذا الذي لا تريد
حركه حماس ولا تريد فصائل المقاومه ومن ثم
فصائل مقاومه متمسكه بضمانات على الاقل في
الحد الادنى ان لم يكن موقف مسبق من شانها
ان تفضي الى وقف هذه الحرب العدوانيه على
الفلسطينيين سموتريتش على وجه التحديد
اعتقد انه دقيق فيما يقول بالنسبه للتعبير
عن مواقفه هو واضح تماما ان احزاب
الصهيونيه الدينيه وسموت في طليعتها ايه
يعطي الاولويه لاستمرار هذه الحرب
العدوانيه على الفلسطينيين داخل قطاع غزه
وهو لا يقيم وزنا اصلا للاسرى
الاسرائيليين لدى المقاومه الفلسطينيه
داخل قطاع غزه بل هو يدعو الى اكثر من ذلك
ويدعو الى عوده الاستيطان الى داخل قطاع
غزه وبالتالي سموتريتش هو يعبر عن مواقف
دقيقه تخصه هو احزاب الصهيونيه الدينيه
التي تحاول ان تبتز بن يمين نتنياهو
وتحاول ان تقطع الطريق على اي جهود من
شانها ان توقف هذه الحرب او ان تفضي الى
صفقه تبادل اسرى من شانها ايضا ان تكبح
هذه الحرب العدوانيه على الفلسط فلسطينيين
داخل قطاع غزه اختلاف هذه المواقف برايي
كيف سينعكس على اجتماع مجلس الحرب المنعقد
الان والذي سيعقبه اجتماع للمجلس الامني
الوزاريه
المصغره اعتقد ان الكيان الاسرائيلي
المؤسسه الاسرائيليه في الحقيقه تعاني الى
حد ما من قدرتها على اتخاذ قرارات مهمه
على صعيد هذه الحرب العدوانيه على
الفلسطينيين في قطاع غزه ليس فقط فيما
يتعلق ب تفاهمات تبادل الاسرى ولكن في
مجمل مجريات هذه الحرب كنا ن نعلم في
الحقيقه ان بنيامين نتنياهو كان دائما ما
يقطع الطريق على ما يسمى بنقاش اليوم
التالي لهذه الحرب يعني بمعنى تحديد الرؤى
السياسيه والاستراتيجيه للكيان الاسرائيلي
من هذه الحرب العدوانيه على قطاع غزه لان
هذا الامر على وجه التحديد هو محل خلاف
بين مختلف الاطراف والفرقاء الاسرائيليين
ولا سيما بين حلفاء بنيامين نتنياهو في
الصهيونيه الدينيه ومن ينجذب اليهم من
وزراء بنيامين نتنياهو داخل اللكود وبين
الاطراف التي قد تكون ذات قدره اكبر على
التفكير الاستراتيجي مثل شركاء بم نتنياهو
في مجلس الحرب مثل جيتس مثل ايزنكوت
وعموما الطريقه التي سوق بها الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي هذه الحرب على الفلسطينيين
داخل قطاع غزه بوصفها حربا وجوديه ومصريه
وان استمرار الكيان الاسرائيلي في فلسطين
منوط بتحقيق هذه الحرب لاهدافها يجعل من
الصعب على اي صانع قرار سياسي ان يتخذ
قرارات جريئه وشجاعه على هذا الموضوع لكن
في الحقيقه انا اعتقد ان صمود المقاومه
الفلسطينيه وتمسكها بشروطها وصمود المجتمع
الفلسطيني داخل قطاع غزه وتعثر الجيش
الاسرائيلي في تحقيقه لاهدافه من هذه
الحرب العدوانيه على الفلسطينيين اي في
غزه وتصاعد ملف الاسرى واحتلاله مكانه
مهمه ومتقدمه على اجنده السجال والنقاش
السياسي داخل اسرائيل بخلاف ما كان عليه
الامر او الحرب من شانه ربما ان يخلق
تحولا مهما اي بما يخالف الاراء الاكثر
تطرفا داخل المؤسسه الاسرايليه نعم وب
باعتبار ان ملف الاسرى هو الذي يتصدر الان
مشهد المفاوضات ما ثقل ورقه الضغط التي تش
تشكلها عائلات الاسرى الاسرائيليين
برايك الحقيقه ان هذا سؤال مهم للغايه لان
الامر لم يكن بهذا النحو في بدايه هذه
الحرب العدوانيه على الفلسطينيين داخل
قطاع غزه كان هناك رهان كبير لدى كل
المؤسسه الاسرائيليه وتحديدا لدى بنيامين
نتنياهو وحلفاء بنيامين نتنياهو في
الصهيونيه الدينيه لطمس هذا الملف تماما
واخراج هذا الملف من النقاش والتداول
والسجال السياسي وكان هناك وعي على الاقل
في في في المرحله الاولى ان هذا الملف
يتناقض مع الاهداف الكليه الكبرى وان
الاسرائيليين ينبغي ان يتحملوا اكلافا
واثمان باهضه من قبيل التضحيه بالاسرى لدى
المقاومه في سبيل انجاز هذه الحرب اهدافها
ولكن علينا ان نتذكر ان بنيامين نتنياهو
الذي كان يقول هذا الكلام وحلفاء بنيامين
نتنياهو رضخوا للمقاومه الفلسطينيه حينما
استعادوا جزءا من اسراهم لدى المقاومه من
خلال تفاهمات وليس من خلال الابتزاز او
فرض الهزيمه العسكريه او فرض التنازل على
الفلسطينيين وهذا يذكرنا بطبيعه نتنياهو
هو منن عادته ان يقول شيئا وان يفعل شيئا
اخر يعني اذا تذكرنا صفقه جلعاد شليط ودعا
اولمرت وانتقد اولمرت يعني دعاه لا يتم
هذه الصفقه مع حركه حماس لكن الذي اتم هذه
الصفقه وانجز هو بنيامين نتنياهو وبالتالي
جزء من كلام بنيامين نتنياهو هو جزء منه
دعايه نفسيه موجهه ضد الفلسطينيين وجزء
منه هو لعب على الحبال والاكاذيب التي
احترفها بنيامين نتنياهو مره اخرى اعتقد
ان الفلسطينيين فصائل المقاومه تمكنت من
ان تجعل لهذا الملف حضورا مهما ومركزات
كبيره على اجنده النقاش والسجال السياسي
بخلاف ما كانت تريد المؤسسه المؤسسه
الاسرائيليه عموما العسكريه والامنيه
والسيا وبالتالي تفاعل هذا الملف وتمكنت
المقاومه من استثاره المجتمع الاسرائيلي
واصبح في هناك شرائح تضغط من اجل اعطاء
الاولويه لملف الاسرى واكثر من ذلك
الحقيقه اصبح في هناك شرائح تناقش فكره
الحرب وجدوى الحرب نعم لا يمكن ان نقول ان
هذه الخلافات وصلت درجه حاسمه يعني لا
ينبغي ان نخدع انفسنا وان يعني نبالغ طبعا
في تقدير طبيعه الخلافات الموجوده داخل
الكيان الاسرائيلي لكن من الواضح تماما ان
حصل هناك تحول يعطي هذا الملف اولويه
واهميه كبرى وهذا ناجم بالدرجه الاولى عن
تعثر الجيش الاسرائيلي وناجم ايضا عن صمود
الفلسطينيين